but if the centuries
of history that is being written before our eyes
it's incredible
[Music]
to
oh
m
when we showed up the fire was
already very violent very powerful at the
level of the art of the arrow around  of
the arrow the fire with country so we
tried to establish means of
important relics but it was quickly considered that
this part of the fire it could
not be saved that to its parts of
the building could not be  saved so
at that moment we make a choice we make
a choice and give up attacking the fire
in its place where it took to
save what we can still save
it's a system
in the cathedral
not
find the two belfries
we saved the whole structure
we saved part of the vaults and one to
save all the works that
were inside
[Music]
oh